over the weekend chicago police officer
ella french and her partner made a
routine traffic stop
they approached the vehicle and the
suspects opened fire
officer french shot in the head
she's gone tonight her partner is still
fighting for his life two brothers
emante and eric morgan
22 and 21 years of age were charged in
her murder
joining me now is john canazera
president of chicago's fraternal order
of police
john we heard a story about lori
lightfoot going to see
the officer in critical condition and
his family in the hospital
what happened when she got there
well first of all i want people to say
her name
ella french our city is less safe
because ella french is no longer with us
it's a disgrace but when the mayor
against the wishes of the family
proceeded up to the seventh floor of
that hospital
she was given a little advice by the
officer's father who was a recently
retired cpd member
and he let her know what he thought and
he didn't appreciate her coming up there
and the officers on that floor when she
went to approach them
all turned around faced the other way
and took a couple steps away from her
it was literally an exclamation point to
the sentiment that was
seven fours below on the street level
where i was with several hundred
officers
it was a very palpable angry resentful
just police force and it wasn't just
because of the incident
it was because the mayor was there and
certain brass
who have led to a lot of problems within
this police department
well there's an enormous amount of
pent-up anger
frustration a sense of betrayal
among the officers we had a chance to
talk to today
they wouldn't come on camera words
cannot describe their emotion but al of
french's name
is a name that i'm so glad you said said
it the way you said it
they want everyone to know her name
given what happened
amazing officer yes uh you know she is
the face of what this department was
supposed to be going forward
the city's phrase of be the change ella
was trying to be the change
and because of policies that have been
encouraged
propaganded and actually promoted
by city and state officials these
criminals think they can do whatever
they want with no repercussions
i will tell you you know at the hospital
saturday night you know
a group of members made a stand and
thankfully they did but i just left
the cst unit where allah and officer
yanez were out of
and i spoke to a large contingent of
these officers
after the superintendent had just got
done speaking to them
the mayor was supposed to originally be
at that roll call
they told the members the the exempt
members there that they did not want the
mayor there
and she was not allowed to come and
speak to them thank you
thank you thank you for being with us
tonight this is a heartbreak hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else